é primeiro que agradecer alta de x mauá
pela oportunidade daqui presente a
organização
meu nome é khan mil assentos é isso rede
do lado de inovação da isi e vou contar
um pouquinho pra vocês hoje do que é a
nossa iniciativa é de design de serviços
de inovação
então como michelle brilhantemente
colocou naquele slide que mostra os
carrinhos da ford
a gente vem de um sistema de ensino
fabril que massificar as pessoas que não
não acredita no poder individual de
construir e o que isso tem causado você
fica preso no sistema de ensino por 20
anos que max fica você coloca você em
todas as caixas possíveis e imagináveis
e quando você sai disse você vai para um
mercado que te cobra e inovação
pensamento criativo disruptivo só que
como que você entrega esse tipo de
pensamento esse tipo de desempenho
se você não foi ensinado pra ele na
verdade se a criatividade foi tirada de
você né uma experiência que é sempre
realizada que é super interessante vocês
podem fazer se tiverem acesso a crianças
é chegar a uma escola e entrar numa sala
e perguntar pra essas crianças que estão
cercados de desenho e de materiais
coloridos galera quem aqui é criativo
quem quer um artista
todo mundo vai levantar a mão todo mundo
vai quase caí da cadeira valeu só isso
conforme você vai progredindo as séries
você vai tendo cada vez menos empate
talvez não queira - crianças levantam a
mão pra você é eo que a gente vê isso se
propaga para a faculdade e o que é pior
com essa essa pessoas a ela se forma
entre para o mercado de trabalho
ela entra uma corporação que cobra dela
um desempenho mas que é completamente
tóxica e adversa a mudança
então o que a gente sabe que o
pensamento criativo ele só acontece
através da experimentação do erro da
liberdade de ser quem você é de criar e
você vai está imerso numa empresa uma
corporação que não permite que isso
aconteça
que coloca metas e pressões em você e
não permite que você se expresse
e isso gera uma grande frustração e uma
desconectam com que a gente faz é não
sei a maioria de vocês não conhece ou já
passou por essa essa sensação né eu não
sei o que estou fazendo aqui
eu gosto de estar fazendo qualquer outra
coisa menos isso acordar segunda feira
pra mim é uma desgraça nettheim dóris
frieden à eu tenho uma reunião e gente a
gente está preso nesse sistema a gente
está navegando o trenzinho de bom eu vou
ficar nessa profissão vou ficar 40 anos
nela e depois eu me aposentar vou para a
terra prometida visitar diversão eterna
só que né a hashtag partir da
aposentadoria eu já tenho todo o plano
da esquematizado
só que esse não é mais a realidade não
só para a geração nova para os milênios
quintão que são acusados de serem muito
16 insolúveis a palavra certa mas assim
que não se apegar muito então o cara
muda de job a cada três meses não tá nem
aí
só que a gente tem visto e deve ter
acontecido com vocês a pessoa que você
conhece pessoas que estão há 20 30 anos
uma carreira chutando o pau da barraca
quando o cara não quer mais fazer isso
vou empreender vou procurar outra coisa
isso não me representa
por quê porque tem essa de conexão isso
é uma coisa real e o que que a aiea
acredita então a gente é a primeira
escola de inovação em serviços do mundo
ea primeira jornada de empreendedorismo
através do design
a gente acredita a em poder a vocês a
retornar nesse poder de construir
você é assim o gênio criativo você
consegue atingir resultados incríveis e
inovarem dependendo independente da área
que você tá só que você esqueceu disso o
sistema bateu tanto na sua cabeça de que
não pode não pode não faz não é assim
que funciona não é desse jeito que vai
funcionar o que você tá com medo agora
você não consegue mais dar um passo para
frente e ter criatividade para inovar
a 1 e como isso acontece então a a
michelle colocou várias tendências de de
ensino hedge e bom de desenvolvimento
que fiquei superfeliz cada vez que ela
mostrava uma coisa nova abriu um sorriso
maior porque tudo que a gente acredita
que é a descentralização do ensino
ensino através do storytelling e da agn
ficar são só que muitas das iniciativas
que a gente tem visto são focadas em
crianças o que é animal
então você está preparando uma geração
de pessoas novas para os desafios de um
mundo complexo
só que o que eu faço com quem já está
pronto
né oi eu não tenho mais cinco anos eu já
me informei que eu faço
então o que a gente propõe é um modelo
educacional que dar uma chacoalhada que
muda uma em 7 para que você que já está
no meio do caminho consiga voltar e
falar não para aí eu posso sim fazer
alguma coisa não necessariamente você
vai chutar o pau da barraca né a gente
tem na escola logo na entrada tem
cuidado alto índice de mencionar é
verdade porque o que a gente faz é
mergulhar a pessoa em uma jornada de
transformação é de seis meses a um ano
então mergulho super profundo por
diversas competências
depois eu falo mais mas isso muda o
tamanho de 7
você começa a acreditar que dá sim para
fazer coisas diferentes
e se você está dentro de uma cultura
tóxica se você está dentro de um lugar
que não permite que você se desenvolva
você sai você fala olha existem outras
coisas que eu posso fazer
eu posso trabalhar em outros lugares por
sabrina perestroika que o animal não
precisa estar aqui né posso trabalhar em
todas as outras iniciativas legais que
vão aparecer ainda hoje e você sai você
vai empreender mas uma das coisas que eu
mais gosto de ver no pessoal que procura
a escola são os entrepreneurs que o
pessoal que empreende para dentro da
corporação que esses são os caras
animais
eles acreditam que eles podem fazer a
mudança de dentro então ele olha e fala
tá meu trabalho sei lá e bmx
eu posso mudar o sistema de pensar daqui
de dentro
então como que você puder essa pessoa
você tem que fazer com que ela acredite
pode mudar isso é só através da holanda
vai doença através do de fazer e de
desenvolver então a gente coloca essas
pessoas ao longo de uma jornada de um
projeto que eles vão desenvolvendo e vão
acreditando e vendo os resultados
acontecerem desde empreendimentos
sociais
a microcamp startup é bom só pra
respirar um pouquinho melhor da da
escola desculpa gente super nervosa mais
tarde tá
vocês são muito legais nunca falei pra
tanta gente assim do tipo ame am então
eu tivesse que dançar é mais fácil mas
falar é difícil então é é a minha linha
básica
esse resgate que a gente tem como que
funciona então por que aí existe a o
estadão falou recentemente é que
aeromodelo 1 mb e alternativo mas a
gente prefere pensar que a gente é uma
alternativa ao ebay
você não precisa nem pra que time b é
boy mas gente desculpa quem tem ninguém
vale muito a pena não se matem não é
nossa intenção foi mal mas eu digo assim
é existem outras formas de pensar né
você pode sair da sua caixinha ea gente
acredita muito no poder individual de
construir e que isso significa que você
é responsável pelo seu conhecimento pelo
jeito como você aprende né então como já
foi mostrado se você aprende por vídeo
ou por experimentação como que funciona
você desenha essa jornada de inovação
você volta ao poder original de escolher
ou não eu quero fazer isso isso e aquilo
eu desenho eu venho os dias que eu
quiser que eu quero ir na escola e eu
vou apresentar um projeto baseado em
necessidades reais em pessoas
então a gente acredita profundamente no
design centrado no ser humano aliás eu
acho que isso é uma redundância falar
design centrado no ser humano
a gente está centrada no design se você
não coloca a pessoa no centro daquilo
não faz sentido é então através da
empatia da colaboração e da
experimentação
o que né são os motes do design thinking
abordagem que a gente utiliza a gente
desenvolve essas pessoas e eu queria
explicar um pouquinho porque porque
design serviços é porque inovação em
design de serviços aí acredita muito
radicalmente que não existem produtos
que tudo o que existem são avatares de
serviço sendo prestados
é o nosso bordão e o que isso implica
que tudo o que existe na nossa vida tá
lá por um motivo uma razão de existir
uma razão de ser
quando a gente encontra alguma coisa
nova a gente pega na mão olha não sei
que é isso para que serve
quando você passa de um pensamento de
produto que é pautado em uma linha de
produção uma cadeia né
quando você pensa em um produto você
pensa ué começa aqui produz lá o cara
consomem joga fora por uma lente de
serviços você automaticamente pergunta
pra quem primeiro e depois o que é então
pra quem eu vou desenhar isso que
necessidade que está resolvendo de fato
quando você começa a pensar dessa forma
você começa a entender que tudo que você
entrega independente da área que você tá
é uma experiência no final do dia que
você está entregando uma experiência
para aquelas pessoas
como que você pode desenhar isso de
outra forma como que você pode desenhar
outros avatares para que essa
experiência seja entregue
você pode desenhar elevatórias por
exemplo é um dispositivo mobile um
telefone celular
ele é um aparelho que permite que você
se conecte ao mundo e outras pessoas que
você se distrai ex de vista que a prenda
mas já se questionaram porque ele tem
aquela forma porque ele é um tijolinho
a tecnologia hoje permite que ele
pudesse ser um bandeira de um óculos
qualquer outra coisa
ele é do jeito que é porque o nosso mapa
mental fala que ele tinha que ser assim
só que eu dar um passo para trás e
falata o que eu tenho que entregar seu
tempo entre a experiência de conexão não
podia fazer sei lá uma orelhinha e que
funcionasse do mesmo jeito
poderia eu poderia nem usar
avatar nenhum poderia que há um cenário
uma experiência de existência onde você
consegue entregar o mesmo tipo de
experiência né e o que que o que a
escola busca fazer
ela busca criar agentes de mudança então
a gente tem uma turma super restrita
disse ela 40 pessoas no máximo
mas a idéia é que você pode sim é mudar
o mundo à sua volta
então se eu conseguir fazer com que você
seja diferente que você acredite no seu
poder inovador que você consegue
entregar você vai contaminar as pessoas
à sua volta
o que acontece muito é que as pessoas
vêm conhecer e começam a jornada e é só
nossa eu não sou o único maluco eu não
sou a única pessoa que está desconectada
porque no primeiro dia de aula se
apresenta é falar então eu tô aqui na
edital porque eu estou buscando uma
conexão e o cara do seu lado fala a
mesma coisa o cara só de falar a mesma
coisa então é um pólo de troca de ideias
e de experiências o que a gente mais
gosta de fazer na verdade é de falar do
que a gente está aprendendo e ensinando
para outras pessoas então é muito comum
você ver as pessoas que saem dando aula
dando curso replicando a gente acredita
muito em não manter o conhecimento
dentro da casa de espalhar é mais do que
uma escola a gente um movimento uma
bandeira uma comunidade
a gente quer impactar o maior número de
pessoas com esse espírito criativo em
poder a dor pra que vocês impacto em
outras pessoas né então se já pararam
para pensar que a vida de vocês vai
mudar e que a vida de muitas pessoas vai
mudar porque vocês estão aqui hoje
porque você está em contato com
conteúdos diferentes e que isso vai pôr
em movimento uma onda de transformação é
esse tipo de coisa que a gente acredita
e reconecta o propósito das pessoas que
você esquece a gente fica feliz de fazer
o que a gente faz então pergunta atacar
mas que você faz o que a rede do lab faz
eu entrego mágica eu falo eu garanto que
essa experiência seja a melhor possível
quebra cabeça o dia inteiro pra pensar
como eu posso entregar a melhor
experiência de ensino pra você de uma
forma criativa é colaborativa e
construtivista
e quando a gente fala em sistemas de
ensino construtivista todo mundo acha
lindo e maravilhoso mas tem aquela
pegada do risco né construtivismo põe na
sua mão o poder de decisão a gente está
lá todo mundo te apoia você pode contar
com todas as gerações que já passaram
todos os inquéritos que já passaram mas
a decisão é sua
por isso que a gente chama na ese o
aluno de explorador e o professor de
conector então não existe uma hierarquia
o historiador não é maior ou melhor que
o conector ou vice versa
o historiador ele tem um espírito de
busca ele veio em busca de alguma coisa
ele está buscando um conhecimento e uma
trilha e um conector vai conectar esse
conhecimento para ele
só que durante essa essa conexão é que
acontece
o a geração de conteúdo de conhecimento
seja dentro de um leve inovador
então onde você pode sentar no chão na
mesa onde for pode ser fora é em que a
gente - a falha de serviço porque dizem
ter visto nada mais é que a entrega de
uma experiência então estudar coisas
diferentes e inovadoras mas é a pessoa
sai da jornada completamente
transformada e diferente ea gente super
apóia todas as iniciativas que são
similares a esse tipo de mudança e que
estão em poder das pessoas então quando
eu venho promoção convidada do evento
desses pra falar da escola e so sorry
por vocês querem assistindo ao meu talão
preto
mas eu sou o lens em apresentação tão
mas assim eu fico super animada porque a
gente não tá falando sozinho a gente
está paranóico e convidando sozinho
existem outras coisas acontecendo e se
conectando ea minha mensagem final pra
vocês é assim quando vocês estiverem
dentro do que vocês fazem entregando a
experiência que vocês entrega de um
passo para trás e se perguntem pra quem
que ela é o que necessidade de fato a
nota resolvendo
será que essa melhor gestora que o
melhor jeito de de entregar isso de
resolver essa necessidade
só com esse simples shift de olhar vocês
vão começar a abrir um pouco a cabeça
entender que você tem muito mais opção
muito mais força
mudança do que vocês têm tá essa é minha
mensagem para vocês
muito obrigada pela presença